ariana grande is officially a married
woman
and now e.t is learning all about her
life as a newlywed with husband dalton
gomez
[Music]
a source tells et that the 27 year old
singer and 25 year old luxury real
estate agent
who tied the knot in an intimate
ceremony last month have really been
enjoying married life
explaining that ari feels happy and very
relaxed
like she's entering a new chapter of
life quote
ariana and dalton felt like before they
were married they couldn't be as open
about their relationship
without it being scrutinized in the
media and now they feel
way more at ease they have plans to
travel more together and
feel closer than ever they enjoy making
unified decisions
as a couple i'm happy life is good
the source also adds that for dalton
ariana is his first priority
in everything they do quote he really
values her
and shows it and when it comes to ari
she loves that dalton is
super chill and how understanding he is
of her
i feel her love every day the couple was
first romantically linked in early 2020
before making it official with an
engagement in december
just a few short months later in may
they got married at the singer's
montecito california estate
at the time ariana who looked
breathtaking as a bride in a column vera
wang gown
shared some of the romantic snaps to her
instagram
[Music]
while the couple keeps their
relationship pretty private
we have seen a few glimpses into their
lives like in the stuck with you music
video
and the time that dalton helped ari
quite literally
make it ring it'll be raining all summer
but we'll surely be dancing as it does
cheers to a lifetime of laughing and
dancing together as mr and mrs gomez